- Welcome back to the Kelly Clarkson Show.
I am your host for the
hour, Kumail Nanjiani.
Kelly is out sick, so
I am in charge today,
which means the show is a
Welcome to Chippendales Takeover!
(audience applauds and cheers)
(upbeat band music)
We have even turned the
Blake Shelton box seats
into a small nightclub.
Hey guys!
(audience cheers and applauds)
Yeah,
Yeah.
Our first guest is the
woman who plays my wife
in the series.
So see, Welcome to Chippendales
might seem like a show
about strippers,
but at the center of
every great story is love.
This woman is a crazy talented
actress, dancer, and singer.
She's even won a Tony for her performance
in "You Can't Take It
With You" on Broadway.
(audience cheers and applauds)
Say hello to Annaleigh Ashford.
(upbeat music)
(applause)
(audience cheers and applauds)
- Hello band! Yes!
Hi!
Yes, band! Yes.
- How's it going?
- Hi!
Hey buddy, how's it going?
You're hosting a show!
- I am.
(audience claps and cheers)
- Who knew?
- Yeah. It's weird.
It's like,
(Annaleigh laughs)
- [Annaleigh] It is.
- You're on Kelly Clarkson, but I've,
- Yeah. Where is Kelly?
- [Kamal] She's,
- And why are you here?
- I don't know.
This is a nightmare you're having.
- It's the Welcome to
Chippendales Takeover!
- Yeah, it is. (laughs)
(audience cheers and applauds)
- Was there a band?
- It only works when I say it.
Welcome to Chippendales Takeover.
(upbeat band music)
(Annaleigh laughs)
So you are like a really great dancer.
You're like a trained, stage dancer,
but what do you think of
the dancing on our show?
What do you think of all
those guys over there?
- Oh, these
(audience cheers)
I love you guys!
(lips smack)
I mean, these boys are the best.
I always like to tell everybody
that all of these sweet boys,
not only are they fierce at dancing,
but they are beautiful actors
who gave each of their boys
a story and a love and a life and a heart,
and like, I'm really proud
that we got to play with them.
- [Kamal] Yeah.
And they were so,
(audience cheers and applauds)
so wonderful to have on set too.
Always, it was like this
energy every day going to work.
- Yes. Every day.
- Hard to play.
You know, I realize we haven't
really talked about the show.
Do you want to tell 'em
what the show's about
and who you are and all those things?
- Sure, sure, sure.
- [Kamal] Do my job for me.
- Okay, great, great.
(audience laughs)
Well, what's I think super
special about this piece is,
yeah, we all know the
pop culture kind of magic
of the Chippendales dancers.
We all just think of the boys,
and that's what you're gonna think of.
But my mom is actually
a true crime aficionado,
so she enlightened me about the real story
of the Chippendales Dancers
and it was a true crime sensation.
Hey, is this gluten free?
(audience laughs)
- I don't know if it's gluten free.
Is it gonna?
- Yeah, but here, I'll just
have a little whipped cream.
That's,
Mm! Delicious!
Was it in his pocket?
- Yeah, it was in his pocket.
(audience laughs and applauds)
- Ooh, it's Banana-ey too!
- Yeah, it's got banana in it.
- Oh, it's delicious.
So yes, there's murder,
there is some mayhem,
there's a lot of love, there's
some very, very good dancing.
But, I think it's gonna
be surprising how dynamic,
and I think beautiful the story is.
- So you were a club dancer?
You're not, not like a strip,
(audience laughs)
not like,
no,
(Annaleigh chuckles)
not a strip club dancer.
(audience laughs)
But you were like a dancer in a club.
- I was a go-go dancer,
doing interpretive dancing
at a 70s glam rock party.
(audience cheers and applauds)
Oh! That's me holding The Sweet album.
- [Kamal] Can you still do those moves?
- (clears throat) I mean,
my hip is a little older,
but you know, I can still throw down.
- Can you prove it?
(audience cheers and applauds)
- I need the boys.
Can I go up with the boys?
Am I allowed to go?
I used to dance on like a
platform, like where the boys are.
- Why don't you do this?
Why don't you walk up there,
dance with them,
(audience applauds and cheers)
and then I'll take us back,
I'll give you time,
(audience applauds and cheers)
and I'll take us out to a break, okay?
- But I'll wait for you to get up.
Annaleigh Ashford.
(audience applauds and cheers)
Look at her.
It should take her.
Use the stairs, Annaleigh. There you go.
There's no elevator. This isn't the show.
They don't carry you up the stairs here.
- Okay, you ready?
- Yeah. Here we go.
We need to stop for
another commercial break.
But we've got Murray Bartlett
from our Hulu series,
Welcome to Chippendales,
(audience cheers and applauds)
joining us next!
Dancers and Annaleigh,
(upbeat band music)
(Annaleigh laughs)
(audience applauds)
- [Kamal] Wow!
- [Murray] Hey, before we
start, can I try something?
- [Kamal] Yes.
- Hi, I'm Murray Bartlett,
and Welcome to Chippendales Takeover!
(upbeat band music)
(audience cheers and applauds)
- Yay!
- Okay, now it works!
- Annaleigh, why don't you try it?
- Welcome to the Chippendale's Takeover!
(audience cheers)
(Murray and Kamal laugh)
- Wait, too bad?
- Wah, wah, wah, wah
- I don't know why
it doesn't work when you say,
"Welcome to Chippendales Takeover?"
(upbeat band music)
(Murray laughs)
(audience laughs and applauds)
Hey, it's great to be back
together, isn't it guys?
- It is! It sort of feels,
I feel like I've woken up in a dream
where my brother is the
host of a talk show,
and I'm sitting next to my sister.
- Oh
- Yeah.
- [Murray] What is happening?
(Annaleigh laughs)
Yeah
- Hey, congrats on your Emmy!
White Lotus.
My God!
- Yeah!
(audience cheers and applauds)
- Thank you, thank you.
- So well earned!
- Thank you.
Yeah
- Wow. So good.
- Yeah, it was.
It was a pretty epic
night that Emmy's night
because we shot White Lotus in the,
sort of the beginning of the pandemic,
and then we didn't really
see each other, that cast,
for a long period of time
'cause we were, you know,
thick in the pandemic.
So the Emmy's night, when a
lot of the cast was nominated,
was one of the first times
we were all back together,
so it felt like this beautiful reunion,
and then, you know,
we were blessed to keep
winning awards that night,
so it was just this like sort
of ramping up of excitement
for all of us.
It was really,
- Yeah, you won them all.
(audience cheers and applauds)
- [Murray] It was a bit
of a sweep, I have to say.
Yeah, it was,
- [Kamal] It was a bit of a sweep.
Well deserved.
- Thank you.
- I mean, that show's fantastic,
and you were so good in it.
(audience cheers and applauds)
- Thank you.
- I remember, I ran
into you at the airport
the very next day.
- Yes.
- You did?
- And you were just
there with your backpack,
- Randomly.
- and I was like,
yeah, I was like, "Where's your Emmy?"
He's like, "I checked it."
You checked your Emmy?
- You did?
(audience laughs)
You didn't have it in your carry-on?
- [Kamal] No he didn't!
He just gave it to, like,
"Put this in the bottom of the plane."
(audience and Murray laughs)
Well, we had such a good time
on the sugar dance scenes,
you know, they had some real
like bachelorette party energy.
Well, how did you guys feel, like,
during those dance scenes?
You choreographed them.
(Annaleigh and Murray laugh)
I mean, your character.
- Yeah.
I pretended to.
I mean, I remember, like,
I think we shot some
of those first Chippendales
Club scenes about a week
into the shooting of the show.
And so we were, you know,
in the sort of the flow
of doing scenes and stuff,
and it was great.
I mean, it was great from the beginning,
but those days that we we started shooting
the Chippendales Club scenes,
I don't think we were
prepared for the intensity
of the kind of glee of the 200
plus like, background actors
it was especially
noticeable when, you know,
you have a bunch of background actors,
and they have to do
their actions sometimes
and not make the sound,
so the dancers come out,
and the background actors are all going
(audience and Annaleigh laugh)
You know, all that kinda stuff,
but not making any sound.
So, we were doing one of those takes,
and the dancers come
out, they do that thing,
and the background actors are, like,
and then they yelled, "Cut,"
and all the background
actors went "Waahhhh!"
(Annaleigh and audience laugh)
There was this incredible,
and then when we were
shooting the coverage
when they were actually,
like, giving it full out,
it lifted the roof off.
Do you remember that?
- Every single time we did,
every single time those guys danced,
people, the background, would go wild.
- Yeah.
- They would, like, love it,
even though they weren't supposed to.
They ruined takes because
they couldn't not squeal
when you guys ripped your pants off.
That's gotta feel pretty good.
(audience laughs)
- But it was also like a
revelation for us, I think,
of what it must have been like
in those Chippendales clubs.
Like, there's something about
putting semi-naked people
in front of a bunch of other people
that just makes people go wild.
Yeah, it was,
- Yeah, it makes you go, "Oh,"
when you're not supposed to.
(audience laughs)
- Yeah, there's a lot of that.
Yeah.
- Up next, after the break,
we have Quentin Plair,
who is absolutely fantastic in the series.
So we'll be right back.
(audience applauds and cheers)
- Wow
- Hey!
- [Quentin] Wait, hold on,
Kamal. Before we get started,
- [Kamal] Yeah.
- You're hosting the Kelly Clarkson show.
(Annaleigh and Murray laugh)
- Yeah, I am.
- But, is it the Welcome
to Chippendales Takeover?
(upbeat band music)
- [Kamal] Yeah. Wow.
- This is the Welcome to
Chippendales Takeover!
(audience cheers and applauds)
(all laugh)
I feel like Snoopy.
- Okay.
(Quentin laughs)
It's getting sad now.
- Okay. Alright.
(sad music plays)
Hey, good to to see you again man.
How's it going?
(Annaleigh and Murray laugh)
- I'm good. I'm happy,
I'm happy to be here.
Happy to shout up my dancers up there.
What's up guys?
(audience cheers and applauds)
- So, Quentin, obviously,
you play one of the dancers
on our show.
- Yes, yes.
I play Otis.
- What was it like for
you filming the routines?
I mean, you worked so hard for 'em.
- [Quentin] Yeah, yeah.
No, I mean, it was tough obviously.
Like I have no dance background,
so I had to do two months of choreography,
two months of dance training,
before we even started five
days a week, hours every day.
So, yeah.
- And people don't,
people don't know this.
You were so buffed coming into the show
that we had to ask you
to stop working out.
(all laugh)
- Yes.
- 'Cause you were making
all those guys look bad.
(Murray laughs)
- So I thought, you know,
the first iteration had
the guys from Venice Beach,
these bodybuilders.
So when I got it, I just started lifting.
Got the biggest I'd ever been.
I got this call from Nora and she's like,
"Hey, we saw the tape you sent in.
Thank you so much, could you
please never work out again?"
(Kamal and audience laugh)
And so, yeah.
Yeah. I had to drop about 20 pounds
before we actually started filming.
- [Annaleigh] Of muscle, of muscle.
- Yeah.
Oh, of muscle.
- The guy had to drop
20 pounds of muscle.
- Yeah.
(audience cheers and applauds)
- And him minus 20 pounds of
muscle still looks amazing!
You look so good on the show.
- Thank you, thank you.
- Really?
[Audience Member] Take it off!
(all laugh)
- [Murray] This isn't
actually the Chippendales.
- They said, "Take it off."
- Tune in to Hulu.
You can see me take it all off.
(audience laughs)
- Yeah, go to Hulu.
You can watch it now.
All your dreams will come true.
- I actually,
(audience laughs)
it feels weird seeing you in clothes.
(all laugh)
I'm kidding.
- [Murray] So that's what he looks like.
(all laugh)
So now, you're like good at dancing.
If you were,
you are.
- Yeah, Okay.
- You are.
I'll take it.
(Murray laughs)
- If you had to be a
stripper in real life,
like what are your stripper names?
(audience laughs)
You know, it's like the first pet,
and the street you grew up on.
- Okay. All right.
- So what's your stripper name?
- So, so my first pet
was a dog named Rusty.
- Rusty.
- Golden Retriever
- Already a great start.
(Annaleigh laughs)
- [Quentin] Great start, right?
Wait for this.
And so, my street name growing
up was Still Farms Court.
But we're just gonna break that down.
Go with Rusty Farm.
(audience cheers and applauds)
- Rusty Farms.
- [Annaleigh] So good.
(applause)
- Oh my God, that really works.
Annaleigh, if you were
a stripper, (chuckles)
- Well, I just thought of this.
- [Murray] If she were a stripper?
- If I were,
- I'm kidding. I'm kidding.
(all laugh)
- Nobody wants to see me strip.
It would be the weirdest, most,
- [Murray] You busted
on some moves up there.
- That's some interpretative dancing.
(audience cheers and applauds)
I think a great stripper name,
I just thought of it just this
minute, would be Magic Beans.
(audience cheers and applauds)
(Annaleigh laughs)
- Okay.
- All right.
(all laugh)
- You plant them, and
then those stalk grows.
- Ladies and Gentlemen, Magic Beans!
(Annaleigh laughs)
- What would yours,
what's your name, Murray?
- We had a budgerigar.
Do you know what a budgerigar is?
- [Annaleigh] (laughs)
No, is that the name?
A budgerigar.
It's a small parrot.
They're native to
Australia, where I'm from.
We had a budgerigar, a
series of budgerigars
that we all called the same
name 'cause they kept dying,
which is terrible.
(audience groans)
I mean, they don't have a very long life,
and they like, they get
excited, and they like fly into,
anyway, it was a sad story, but
they were all called Herman.
So that would be my,
my first name,
(Annaleigh and audience laugh)
and my, the street that I
lived on when I was a kid
was called Weaponess Road.
(Annaleigh gasps)
Herman Weaponesss.
- [Annaleigh] Yes!
(audience cheers and applauds)
- That's really good!
- Yeah.